I am just back
from the great city of San Francisco oh
really how was it I love San Francisco
did you have a good time how was it nice
uh now I'm sensing some is it anger
resentment what hat what happened here
we're pissed yeah you're pissed because
let me explain to our listeners
that uh
I was asked uh to to go to San Francisco
um to assist uh former First Lady
Michelle Obama uh with promotion uh for
her
um latest book The Light we carry and
um because no one can get the word out
on a book like Conan O'Brien and so uh I
went and uh Mrs Obama very kindly said
that she would uh do our podcast well
that was up there so I thought I should
take all necessary personnel with me
yeah so I took Eduardo Eduardo did you
have a good time
it was it was good yes you don't have to
feel bad you never necessary
Eduardo you came with me because you are
an excellent sound engineer it was and
Aaron Blair as or as I call you blay you
came along too I did thanks for uh
thanks for having me yeah I don't even
know what you did to be honest with you
why yeah
yeah
why
stop making mouth noises
I mean I I feel like I I facilitate I I
I lubricate uh social lubricants you
know we shouldn't be mad at him yeah I
think I think I've been a brilliant
thing which is I immediately identified
Apollo Davis came along
Adam was there Adam Sandler in this room
Adam sacks was there because I think
Adam put it best when he said I get to
go I think that's what he said all we
have to do he said I get to go now
listen
um no you two were not invited along we
have to keep costs down and you're
expensive Sona you have all these
demands when you travel I am not
expensive you're very expensive I think
that you are you always ashamed of us a
little bit no I'm not ashamed at all I
think what it is is he doesn't he's
afraid that we're gonna charm Mrs Obama
yeah too much and he doesn't want that
tension taken off of him I you know what
else I think you know what else is okay
we went to Milwaukee
to interview her yeah then we did a zoom
interview her second interview Matt and
I wrote at both of those I know then you
go to this third one and suddenly we're
not there she thinks you probably like
fired us I know well first of all hey
should remember you
um well she meets a lot of people uh
also we weren't invited to the Barack
Obama session either and now I'm
starting to sense a pattern it's making
me real uncomfortable but there is no
pattern because we've been there for two
of them so this doesn't make it what
about the possibility that you've had
your chances to hang with Michelle Obama
and it may be at I'm the host of the
thing I know but we've got oh my God and
you could have stayed oh yeah that would
have been a great conversation yeah oh
Mrs Obama tell us what you like about
Cher
what does she like what about Cher
what's your favorite flavor of edible
finally a fresh uh perspective oh all
the questions
where did you shoplift when you were 24
yes yes these are the things people want
to know what did you ask girl how was it
like growing up in the south side of
Chicago like she hasn't been asked that
like 10 000. I asked fascinating
questions
just edited it this morning and it was
lacking a certain let's say soda and
Matt oh
what a terrific podcast we have where
prior to the interview with Michelle
Obama you announced to the people who
can decide whether or not they want to
listen to it or not it's lacking
something it is what if lacking the two
of us yeah
what a crewy organization hi chuckle he
has he had quips you probably needed
them yeah
um I'm gonna say that
um well I think we should ask Adam sacks
Adam sacks you were there and you're a
fair man
um how do you think do you think this
interview is worth people's time Adam
that's a trick question yeah do you
that's a trick question did you like the
interview I had with Mrs Obama because I
think I'm not going to kidding around
this is my favorite one
I feel bad because I I think that Matt
and Sona do really add
a hell of a lot to the podcast yeah yeah
but are always great and I think they
would have been they would not have
taken away from the interview that you
had with Mrs Obama they might have added
something right but I also think it's
true that this is the best the best
conversation but yeah it's a really good
one and I'll say something else but you
both have to remember is that when
you're talking to someone like uh
Michelle Obama who was the first lady of
this nation for eight years when you're
talking to someone uh in that upper
upper upper upper upper echelon
um background checks are involved and I
gorley to be fair I think you're
probably probably involved with the John
Birch Society sometime in the late 80s
there was some weird whatever you've got
some weird skeletons in your closet I'm
more liberal than you you Arch
conservative you know what John Birch
decided you were arrested uh you
arrested once with uh three
ventriloquist dummies and you were in
the park now that that is what you're
doing exactly it was listening these are
background checks excuse me what's that
what'd you say would you say I was funny
this is a Michelle Obama podcast why
can't you hold it together said it
quietly oh yeah into an expensive
microphone yeah that's designed to catch
the sound of cells dividing
and you have to go there with that
ventriloquist dummy in the Park yeah all
right and that always means he's [ __ ]
up
[ __ ] them I was making love to them
there's a huge difference he always buys
him wine first Jesus you know you know
that you would not survive a background
check you're in this country illegally
you've done all kinds of stuff no we've
first we've met her yeah we've already
been checked I met her we've been vetted
yeah so you didn't take us
she got better background check people
oh better than
what yeah the first two times she was on
the show she was dealing with a really
bad background check organization and
she was always talking to the wrong
people and it was bad she was doing them
herself yeah she's just Google searching
us yes checking people out yeah and uh
so anyway uh no this was I'm sorry that
you guys couldn't be there no you're not
I'm not sorry and listen I have to
follow you know Adam has very strict
dictates about keeping things
no I would have loved for you guys to be
there
oh wow okay all right I just
it's an important said no it's an
important interview and it has to go
just right and excuse me excuse me
excuse me excuse me and you are I'm
sorry Matt you're a Loose Cannon and
this one brings up uh ventriloquist
[ __ ] every 10 minutes I can't have it
you bro Chris dummies and when we first
I said ventriloquist dummies
no don't say oh you brought up
ventriloquist dummies so therefore
you're a monster that's what you meant
and when we went out the first time to
Milwaukee we were Model
co-hosts her Sidekicks we barely peace
to be fair you've gotten more
comfortable though and that's a risk is
that what it was yes
okay
Tupperware Adam
is coming from and this is true Matt
um you are not the same guy that went to
Milwaukee you were very buttoned down
and professional then
you uh you love getting the laughs the
chuckles you'll say the uh aberrant
errant quip every now and then and we
all love you for it but I cannot have
that kind of behavior
I would never ever please are you
oh
why are you keeping us from the Obamas
though seriously what is it why why
don't you let us why can't you let us I
think there's a chance if I play my
cards right that I could get into the
Obama Inner Circle oh no and be invited
like you know when they're getting
together with their best friends from
Chicago from those days like their best
best best friends that I'm there too no
now you call that delusional if you want
but this is the long game and I can't
take a chance on you two idiots I just
can't you're out of control Sona and
Gorly I know that you have some horrible
horrible skeletons in your closet I
can't prove it but I can't take the risk
uh I just don't know what what we should
say is should we just Branch out on our
own maybe yeah I think that me and you
know what me and Matt we're we're gonna
start booking our own Conan O'Brien
needs a friend episode with Melania
Trump when yeah we're gonna do it do it
without you because we really do need a
name I think that is well still yeah
we'll still use it all right listen
listen if you feel badly I'm sorry and
next time I'll get you on board okay you
won't I will no you won't I didn't say I
mean I will I really will and you can
hear it in my voice and I'm really gonna
do it and we know we know how to be
behaved when when the guest demands it
you know okay well all right yeah just
you know yeah you know I can you guys I
can trust you like around Sarah
Silverman but that's it you know
um you know what I mean but what about
you yeah you can't be trusted yeah you
of all people shouldn't be talking to
the first lady I agree with you
I agree with you 100 event but that's
the way it went down all right and I
blame the Obamas for the report
decisions
but they need to raise their podcast bar
uh anyway
um I did miss you guys
um no you didn't okay leave it alone
you're trying to wrap it up and you're
saying things that are all false glad I
didn't bring you yeah uh it went so well
what you're about to hear refreshing
what you're about to hear is uh free of
you know it's like you guys are the pulp
in the orange juice and some people
don't want the pulp uh this is just
beautiful clear wonderful pulp-free
orange juice